restaurant scene up in north las vegas
is really expanding yeah construction is
underway on a number of developments all
along craig road we're talking about
running from north 5th street out to
bruce
17 of them are going to be sit down
restaurants sally jeremiah is live with
the notable names coming soon hi there
sally
hey brian and denise right now all we
have is construction but soon all of
this will become a restaurant roll
filled with many food options and job
opportunities
there was nothing here i have pictures
of you know this barren corner of land
steve dunn is the managing partner for
the north las vegas texas roadhouse he
moved here from washington state for
more opportunities in 2018. there's
great people around very diverse
community
very i mean really good feeling of
neighbor dunn adds as people are moving
in record numbers to north las vegas
it's a great area to be in all these
areas are just booming craig road is the
exact center of north las vegas so
between the north and the south that's
about the center position there but
we've got some fantastic restaurants
coming new prototype restaurants north
las vegas mayor john lee says these are
some of the dining spots to look forward
to bj's restaurant and brew house fly
pie pizza panera bread born and raised
tavern dutch bros chili's olive garden
and the list will be expanding i think
that in north las vegas that people
really enjoy eating out and they like
variety but more than that they like to
do it in their hometown that's pretty
pretty exciting i mean this is a nice
area and i like you know taking her out
and having fun james lee says he's
looking forward to having a bj's brew
house in the neighborhood they have the
pazuki's the pizza cookies
those are really good the city you're
looking at today will be the epicenter
of economic industry five years from now